on Spider-Man 3 I have this really quite
intense sequence with Doc Ock where I'm
upside down and he's like battering me
into this wall just constantly and I was
upside down all day for 11 hours and
like honestly I really have nothing to
complain about you know being Spider-Man
has changed my life but I am absolutely
gonna complain about this day it was
brutal you know I was upside down the
blood's rush into your head you're in a
harness the director's saying can you
just turn your head that way and you're
like oh [__] off
so anyway so you come down I'm driving
home at the end of the day
and I'm complaining I'm whinging about
the day I'm like you know I'm so tired
and he's working me so hard and I just
want to break and my brother Harry is
like mate you're Spider-Man suck it up
and get on with it you'll be fine so the
next day on set I'm chatting to the
director about the week's work coming
and he's telling me about this scene
they need a young person to play a
burglar who's Spider-Man's going to
catch he's going do you think Harry
would want to do it I'm like bollocks to
Harry he's doing it
we hi Harry we've got us Harry he's on
set I go up to the stunt coordinator and
I'm like please just whatever you do
with the stunt make it so that he's
upside down
so we're doing this scene Harry's upside
down swinging back and forward and bless
him he's doing a really good job and as
the day is going on he's got these lines
and he's starting to forget his lines
and his eyes look like they're gonna pop
out of his head so we're driving home
that day
and I was actually really proud of him
but he's driving him that day and he's
like mate you can complain as much as
you are that was brutal and I was like
well mate you know but the icing on the
cake and I don't think he actually knows
this we saw the film the other day and
they've cut the scene
[Applause]
nothing's made Tom laugh more than that
to me you said to me he goes you know
mate it was really tough but I was just
really excited about being in a
Spider-Man movie
it's nice to be you bro
it was an elaborate prank yeah it was a
horrible any other Universe he is yes
in the deleted scenes yeah
[Music]